If you're struggling to land that dream job,...
...there might be a secret culprit: the font on your resume.
Hey, I'm Mike Janela for Buzz60.
Now, you're not supposed to make Internet videos with too much text in them,...
...but I'm trying to help you get a job here.
And a new study is out,...
...showing us which fonts are the best and worst to use on a resume.
The best of the best?
That's Helvetica according to the professional typographers...
...consulted by Bloomberg Business.
The pros describe the 60-year-old font as...
...professional, lighthearted, honest and beautiful.
Is Helvetica free Friday night?
Other winners include Garamond, which is scientifically easy on the eyes,...
...and Proxima Nova, a softer version of Helvetica,...
...but one's gonna cost you about 30 bucks online.
But these next fonts are ones you should avoid.
Times New Roman?
Yeah, same font you use for every book report in middle school...
...can be seen as lazy and quote, "like putting on sweatpants for a job interview."
You can also forget about Zapfino and anything else in script,...
...Courier and other typewriter-looking fonts.
And if you needed someone to tell you Comic Sans was a bad idea,...
...we've got bigger problems.
Now, go open up Word.
That resume is not gonna Helvetica itself.
Buzz60: Now you know, pass it on.